well the district providing a breakdown
of how many students are back in
buildings along with teachers as well
8 news now reporter kristen drummond has
those numbers and an update
about coming back a day to remember it
is like the first day of school it just
it's a little bit cooler
than an august start but it's just
really exciting to see our kids
ccsd superintendent dr jesus jarrah
visits rex bell elementary with state
superintendent joan ebert
it's a joyous day both greet students
while
overseeing the adjustment to hybrid
learning how does this opening
compare to the other school districts
around our state
very similar you know a lot of anxious
wondering what it's going to be like to
get back in
in school ccsd says nearly 22
000 students are in the group that was
back in buildings today
that group is called cohort a they will
attend class on campus monday and
tuesday
and online remotely wednesday through
friday roughly 20 thousand
in cohort b going to class online monday
through wednesday
and in person thursday and friday more
than 50 000
are in cohort c which is full-time
distance education
since last thursday more families
switched to cohorts a and b
from c a trend likely to continue this
school year
we are expecting to see an increase in
those students coming into face to face
superintendent jarrah says a total of 4
thousand 485 pre-kindergarten to third
grade teachers worked today
nearly 3 000 were on a campus and around
1500 worked remotely
adapting to change while the district
welcomes the return of students
in classrooms kristin drummond 8 news
now
families interested in switching their
child's cohort need to contact their
school directly
some may have a wait list though for
in-person learning